british prime minister theresa may also
made a brief statement today about the
mass shooting in las vegas
reaction to events in las vegas well
i've just spoken to president trump to
pass on my condolences and that of the
whole country
upon this appalling attack that has
taken place in las vegas this was an
individual shooting randomly a
completely senseless and cowardly attack
and so many people have been killed and
injured and our thoughts and prayers are
with all those who've been victims of
this terrible attack
and it seems as if this was not
terrorist related
well the investigations are continuing
at the moment i have offered the united
states every assistance that we can to
support them in their investigation and
obviously we wait to hear what their
verdict from that investigation is and
do we know anything about british
casualties the foreign office is working
actively through its uh consular uh
consular general with the las vegas
authorities to assess whether there are
any british nationals involved in this
and of course we will provide every
support possible to the las vegas
authorities and to any families if there
are any british nationals involved but i
would urge british nationals in the area
to listen to the advice of the las vegas
authorities
prime minister thank you very much
thank you